foreign
[Music]
briefing for Wednesday March 1st I'm Zoe
Thomas for The Wall Street Journal
electric vehicles offer a lot of promise
for a Greener future but a combination
of vast computing power and numerous
online connections also make EVS a
target for cyber attacks According to
some experts Bart Ziegler wrote about
this for the wsjs journal reports and
joins us now to explain the risks and
possible solutions hi Bart thanks for
being here you're welcome so many
listeners will know that modern cars
whether they're gas powered or electric
powered have a lot of computer chips in
them so why is it that cyber Security
Experts are particularly worried about
EVS being hacked
well you're right modern cars do have
chips in them but electric vehicles have
vastly more one analyst told me that a
high-end standard internal combustion
luxury car might have 150 or so what
they call Electronic control units and
EV could have 3 000 in it basically
because everything in an EV is
electronic
Brio here I mean if a hacker
car does that mean they're going to I
don't know drive me off a cliff or into
a lake well I think there's a whole
gradation of what could happen they
could try similar to what they do with
computer networks to lock people out
basically a ransomware attack where they
could force people to send the money to
be able to start their car again there
could be worse scenarios where they
might do the damage to your car if they
take over the charging system an
electric car that the actual charging
drawing of the power into the batteries
is controlled by software and ships the
transmission of that power from the
batteries to the electric motors is
controlled by chips even though what
they call regenerative braking where you
actually are recharging the battery when
you break an electric car that's all
software and chips so if they get into
that they could damage it or the worst
scenario I've heard is they could
actually cause your batteries to
overcharge and potentially heat up at
night which could course be a horrible
situation they also could do things to
control possibly the steering or braking
or acceleration since those are all
controlled by computers there was one
scenario in 2015 where computer
researchers security researchers broke
into a non-electric car through its
internet connection and Cellular
Connection and caused it to drive
erratically and even to drive into a
ditch that was a test there was no one
hurt but it showed the danger of all
these connections that modern cars have
so a lot of potentially very scary
scenarios there how would hackers
possibly gain access to a car well
that's the other aspect of electric
vehicles that differs from today's
standard internal combustion Vehicles
there are many more communication
Pathways electric cars typically
communicate back and forth with car
company that made them with sometimes
with a dealership and when you plug it
in which many people will be doing daily
it's connecting with the supplier of the
charging station and sometimes with
electric utility behind it and even a
lot of the Chargers especially the
public ones have cellular or other
internet connections so there are lots
of Pathways that experts say hackers
could try to to break into it
the charging stations or charging points
are the Real Pain Point here potentially
can you explain a little bit more about
how they could play a role I mean might
this have a knock-on effect if one
hacked car is plugged into a charging
station could it mean that other cars
that get plugged in have a similar issue
that's one of the potential risks if
hackers manage to infect one car with a
certain type of software that could then
be transmitted to the charger itself
when that car owner plugs in and from
the charger if it could propagate itself
the entire charging Network through the
computers that run these Central
charging public charging stations that's
possible that would be sort of a
different way to get into the entire
system of a larger number of electric
cars but the other thing that we've got
to think about is car makers tend to
send electronic updates to their
electric vehicles and that's done
wirelessly and the fear there from cyber
security researchers is if hackers would
get into that somehow they could
distribute dangerous software to two
hundreds thousands maybe millions of
electric vehicles
you mentioned one test
Security Experts to
happen in a
car have we
any attacks so far on EVS that's the
upside we've not aside from you know
minor glitches and things but that
doesn't mean it couldn't happen I think
the concern here is the state of cyber
awareness and cyber security protocols
in both the electric vehicle industry
and the charging industry are fairly
weak cyber Security Experts told me it
was sort of at a very early phase of
that becoming an issue and a concern
that so much of what this young industry
has been doing is just trying to get the
products out the door and hasn't given
enough thought they say towards the
cyber security controls that need to be
added to them is the government or any
Regulators thinking about this uh yeah
certainly the government has been in
October the Biden White House gathered a
group of Executives from the various
pieces of the electric vehicle industry
to the White House to talk about the
need for greater security the national
highway traffic safety administration
released new guidelines last year one of
them said you should not have sort of
the crucial pieces of a car the
acceleration the braking the steering
they should not be connected to anything
Wireless so there is thought going into
it there's been a bit of talk in
Congress but there haven't been a lot of
new laws that would mandate these
controls okay so if I'm an electric
vehicle owner listening to this
conversation are there things that I can
do to to keep myself safe you just
should be aware of that like all things
that contain computer chips and are
connected to the internet hacking is a
possibility I would think that if your
car would ever to act erratically you
should immediately stop and get someone
to look at it and not assume it's just
some small glitch Bart Ziggler thank you
so much for joining us for this
conversation you're welcome and that's
it for today's Tech news briefing for
more Tech stories check out our website
wsj.com I'm Zoe Thomas for The Wall
Street Journal thanks for listening
foreign
[Music]